Hales good recipe today we're gonna play
beam ng what is that you may ask I'll
show you all right so a lot of you bros
suggested this game after I played wreck
this car or whatever again so it's a
super realistic car simulator I guess
Wow
I feel like she needs a name Bernie
Burnett is go forth Bernie Bernie you're
steering right I am NOT doing this
Bernie you are crazy Bernie what are you
doing Bernie what happened
let's see how much we can rake it Bernie
Oh God
let's do some gravity whoa don't oh I'm
so sorry Bernie Bernie Bernie you're
free go to the heavens
dad's kidding you're dead
this is so bad this is why you should
not give me any sort of power ever this
is what happens I break the universe
alright let's spawn anyone that one is
still there oh all right we're up in the
sky alright let's see how we handle it
I'm sure I'll be fine don't worry Burnie
hey still going go Bernie I love you yes
faster Bernie faster you can do it I
promise
Oh can't hear you it sounds like you're
choking on Dex
let's make him offroad oh yeah let's
just do a good old one make me proud
Bernie and this was at this moment
Bernie knew he'd [ __ ] up yay
still doing it yes now this is what I
call off-road believe in yourself Bernie
I love you hit the water now I have some
bad news for you Bernie you're not a
submarine what the engine died what
happened
Wow
oh my god what's going on you're not a
Pokemon Bernie get your [ __ ] together
let's try a different vehicle hahahaha
my favorite vehicle ever they're flying
I'm having the time of my life now
rooo what now why would I play as a road
sign Oh Lord sign all road up see that's
what happens when you don't Jesus enough
sir Q gen pigeon make it through that
will be a no let's go baby
whoa come on oh god damn it let's see if
we can beat this course I have 100%
faith in that we can not do it till you
look good damn bad bird that rhymed holy
[ __ ]
Oh Ernie you're my baked Burnie you my
boo
Burnie I love you Burnie do you know
kung fu' Burnie watch out for the pillow
I said what shout for it
that was super close idiot so I
downloaded some [ __ ] now let's [ __ ] I
mean I [ __ ] yeah ah okay what do we got
GTA what the [ __ ] what the fudge cake
how the hell am I gonna do this I can't
even see it it's so [ __ ] big loser
she said I don't know how I make this
fly oh okay alright thanks mom
I'm flying yay oh my wing is I wasn't
flying I'm literally standing still oh
yeah a car
Burnie you jealous [ __ ] how do we lift
left left left left left left left leg
oh there we go huh with Hank we're
flying
I can't tell because of reasons I think
we're missing all our motors what if we
just do this I believe I can fly I
believe I can touch the sky oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] sorry sorry wrong broke
button let's try that again
I believe I can fly Hey look you're
flying Burnie too
flying
whoo Oh
where are we ma'am Oh Oh okay we're good
stabilized stabilized we need to
stabilize yes I'm a born pilot coming in
for landing [ __ ] coming in for landing
number attempt number two
[ __ ] you're a better roll best landing
thank you for flying with peopie
airlines that would be $5.99
just kidding all your money thank you
you're becoming more like your father
all right that was a lot of fun I hope
you guys had fun hanging out with me
today this games pretty cool
I live in link to it if you want to
check it out they were like if you want
to see more of this and I would love to
play some more as always they are some
rows